this view it scares me Department's in
the hospital really we have a
[Music]
friend
good morning I actually moved into this
Hospital accommodation yesterday and I
didn't have much time to unpack properly
so I'm going to quickly organize my
things so I can focus on studying before
my first day
[Music]
back
fresh
scrubs so it's my first time staying at
this Hospital accommodation and my first
day back at medical school so I'm being
extra mindful of how I'm spending my
time here because I want to set good
habits right from the start for example
if I keep procrastinating in this room
I'm going to associate this space with
negative feelings and laziness and that
might lead me to continue those habits
for the next 6 weeks that I'm going to
be here that's why with this Fresh Start
I'm trying to make it
count I usually like watching the
sunrise when I'm studying but honestly
this view is scary to me oh my God
actually there is a lady coming down
because I'm on the ground floor someone
can literally jump scare me and they can
see what I'm doing so I'm going to keep
the curtains
[Music]
closed oh my back this desk setting it's
just so uncomfortable I usually have the
computer on my eye
level
[Music]
this is
nice this is our
[Music]
kitchen we have a
fridge
dropped
[Music]
it this is what we're working
with there's no spoon or for and I
thought there would be some here so I
didn't bring any oh I'll just work with
[Music]
nice
I also realized there's no salt on
pepper so I have to eat my food
[Music]
blend honestly it's not bad at all I
think it's because it has cheese in it
which is already salty so the next time
I'm coming here I'm going to meal prep
at home so that's I don't have to cook
here my first block of the year is an a
department which is accidents and
emergency usually trauma injuries and
other emergencies like Strokes or heart
attacks go there now I'm going to
refresh my memory by doing some practice
questions because during the summer
holiday my medical knowledge got Rusty
and like always we have an exam coming
up in a month it will be good practice
for the T
[Music]
one okay let's get ready because it's
the first day I'm going to actually put
effort to look put together but I can't
promise to keep this up for the rest of
the
year but even when I don't have time to
put makeup on I never skip sunscreen and
this is my main one at the moment it's
is in tree onion new pair sunscreen I've
been recommending this to all my friends
hi try this oh my God this is so good
ooh
sunscreen oh wow it's so goody a bit
comy it Blends in so well with my skin
tone it's so smooth white she definitely
want to get some going in my bag it's
purple tinted so it helps blow pores and
neutralizes discoloration the purple
tint becomes seamless in all skin colors
it has 5% Red Onion extract from muang
Korea which helps give your skin a
really nice glow it's not sticky at all
and it feels really lightweight and I'm
really happy to say that thank you isant
Tre for sponsoring this part of the
video now all the finally medical
students like going to have an indu
ction or orientation then we're going to
go to our allocated departments in the
hospital for our clinical
[Music]
rotation we just finished the induction
heading to a
department going to get my ECG
competency signed off and to charge this
first though has no battery
[Music]
left
we're just having a lunch break it's
around 2:00 also we moving in Nicole to
the accommodation that's the kitchen
Lely did you go anywh tonight no I just
had an early night six bedrooms six
bedrooms but I think only four girls are
in the accommodation so far
I've been asked to take some floods from
a patient so now I'm in the clean
utility room to gather some
equipment why are you laughing I'm like
so unprepared I'm not prepared either we
had like a workshop interpreting ECGs
first time I looked at an ECG
since summer right don't tell them that
good first yeah
yeah not on the wards or anything you
didn't see any patients oh god wow it's
actually really warm saying 35° in the
car honestly I didn't bring enough
clothes to barable for that same I
didn't expect it was going to be good
weather or anything how's your day I got
signed off to dots really yeah wow so
dos are basically some assessments that
we need to get signed off until the end
of the year there is 30 of them or
something 24 yeah 24 and I already got
two of them signed off because I'm an
A&E that's the thing yeah there is
always stuff
happening I'm really hungry yeah I'm
really hungry as well I think it's all
the walking we do in the hospital just
generally let's eat
[Music]
AA course
famous how You' been doing that for um a
year what's your name subscri what's
your name
it eat out a thank you so much
F been up to much just Medical
School M bloody you got it all at once
medical school on
[Music]
YouTube that guy was so
sweet when you said I'm hungry you
weren't joking I feel my blood sugar
being l i felt right handed hello cat do
you have my spoon
thank
you we're making pasta pasta it's really
easy but still delicious my top on
student
[Music]
recipe my body forgot have endle this
hectic schedule I'll get used to again
let me give you a tour of the rest of
the
accommodation
can you guess where this door leads to
well this National bed Wedding Day
sticker gives so
[Music]
away there's this huge window on top of
my door which lets in the light from the
corridor and I go to sleep at 8 so a few
hours before the rest of the Medics here
and whenever they're using the corridor
the light wake me up so we'll cover that
with some black bin bags and tape that I
[Music]
borrowed nice staying in a rural old
hospital accommodation might not be the
most comfortable with the good size is
that the staff at small hospitals are
usually very helpful it's my first day
back and I already got signed off for
ECG recording and blood
taking oh my God I to die so